mercadier tu le reconnais mouillart ça
va me souviens on était à la fin qu
ensemble audio ça fait plaisir de te
voir tu changes spot
c'est donc à chaque fois que je prends
l'avion je rencontre quelqu'un que je
connais retiens tu sais qui j'ai vu la
semaine dernière
blanchot et si lent chaud il était avec
nous en fac ya plein de cheveux une
grande barbe mais si blanche on
l'appelait blanchot la nar show un grand
costaud il était toujours en tête dans
les manifs alors drôlement a droit un
pavé un flic un pavé roulement costaud
blanchot il change pas et il a plus de
cheveux il a plus de bars mais ils
changent pas enfin il est content il
épousé la fille d'un magistrat et
l'année prochaine il espère être
commissaire divisionnaire enfin ça
vaille est content à toi tu change pas
non plus hein t'as toujours ta belle
gueule au mot [ __ ] qu'est ce que j'ai
fait des jaloux toi tu nous piquer
toutes les filles
puis alors il en fallait un
quatre par jour
un vrai hop c'est d'être bon as tu peux
plus robot tu fais ce programme ça
soigne
ah non tu peux plus à cause de ton
métier c'est bizarre ça qu'est ce que tu
fais donc hâte évêques belges
je m'en serais pour douter c'est vrai
que maintenant pratiquement vous êtes
habillé comme nous un séverin voit plus
la différence
alors comme ça tu as eu la vocation ah
non c'était pour faire plaisir à ta mère
elle tu aimais beaucoup ta mère bah moi
non je change pas non plus oui ça va je
suis pas mécontent un des poèmes à ses
vrais j'écrivais des poèmes
ouais tu sais je fais plus beaucoup le
temps d'écrire de la poésie
enfin j'écris quand même je suis
journaliste
non pas littéraire non financiers bon eh
ben je suis bien content de t'avoir
revue puis je suis content surtout de
voir que l'on change pas